obviously icon and Tim Cook have a
relationship he could have just sent him
an email what's he trying to accomplish
with this open letter yeah Carl for the
last couple of years has been putting
pressure on Apple to increase its
buyback this isn't the first time Apple
has done responded to several times in
the past most recently earlier this year
saying it was going to increase its
capital return program by 70 billion
dollars through the next two years and
so here is Carl Icahn just a few weeks
later saying hey we'd like to see bigger
buyback he's also Tim saying hey maybe
if you focus on cars and television you
could work something out in terms of red
raising your value but I mean is Tim
Cook really going to listen to what Carl
Icahn has to say when it comes to
products well I think there's it's
interesting he's also talking to the
market in general and he feels like
investors and maybe the media don't
understand the Apple story but there is
a debate of whether the Apple's iPhone
has peaked and the new larger screen 6
and 6 plus have really helped sales in
the last few quarters and now the
question is hake do they have enough to
continue going well the the 6s or
whatever they're going to call it later
this year continue the growth especially
in the US where there's intense
competition and in China where it's
really helped sales in the last few
quarters